monsieur billen Bruno milleniène merci
de nous avoir rejoint dans ce studio
vous êtes député MoDem vous allez tout à
l'heure aborder la question de la
trajectoire budgétaire qui vous tient à
cœur mais d'abord les SZ sont trois
lettres dites nous de quoi il s'agit
vous les défendez oui alors Monsieur
Tanguy moi j'étais j'étais un peu
surpris venant de voix du groupe que en
janvier dernier dans votre niche
parlementaire vous proposiez un texte
qui proposait rien de moins que de
supprimer les zones affaiblissement
mobilité qui sont ces zones qui vont
réglementer la circulation dans le
périmètre de certaines métropoles 43
aujourd'hui un peu moins parce qu'il y
en a qui sortent déjà et c'est une
mesure de de santé publique en fait pour
limiter la pollution la pollution de
l'air j'en avais longuement parlé avec
le porteur du texte pierre Meurin à qui
je reproche un petit peu si vous me le
permettez
d'avoir pas suivi les travaux qu'on a
mené depuis on a commis un rapport avec
Gérard le seul une mission flash sur ce
sujet là qui a bien mis en exergue
effectivement les difficultés et j'ai eu
l'impression j'ai eu l'impression que
cette PPL que vous aviez proposé était
plus quelque chose de l'ordre d'agiter
la peur plutôt que de voir réellement
les travaux qui ont été engagés parce
que je vous rappelle quand même que
juste après la promulgation de ce
rapport une semaine après donc ça va
durer très longtemps le ministère de la
transition écologique s'est engagé
Christophe bechuit s'est engagé à mettre
en place effectivement des groupes de
travail pour qu'on arrive à résoudre les
points épineux moi je vous accorde que
c'était un petit peu nébuleux avant
qu'on fasse le rapport depuis ça s'est
considérablement amélioré et il y a
plein de solutions qui remontent du
terrain pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
lutter contre cette pollution de l'air
qui je le rappelle quand même provoque
48 000 morts par an d'accord et c'est
deux ans un peu plus de deux ans
d'espérance de vie en moins pour les
Français 4 ans et demi par exemple à
Paris donc la question est la suivante
au regard des travaux men
si toutefois vous les avez suivi
souhaitez-vous toujours supprimer les
AFE et le cas échéant quels sont vos
solutions concrètes pour lutter contre
la pollution de l'air dans nos
métropoles oui on veut toujours les
supprimer monsieur Mylène parce qu'en
fait nous n'avons pas la même
philosophie politique sur ce qui est de
la quant à la responsabilité de la
pollution dans nos villes pendant des
années vous le savez les gouvernements
français successifs ont subventionné le
diesel ils ont encouragé à avec des
dizaines de milliards d'euros
deectaxations les Français à s'équiper
en diesel et alors qu'ils auraient pu
mener depuis la première crise
pétrolière dans les années 70 une
politique déjà de développement des
véhicules électriques des mobilités
alternatives fondées sur notre génie
nucléaire vous ils ne l'ont pas fait et
du jour au lendemain on fait porter au
plus modeste d'entre nous au classement
moyenne aussi
parce que laissez-moi finir je vous
écoute bah oui bah si vous avez déjà la
réponse avant la mienne la
responsabilité de lutter contre la
pollution et vous allez progressivement
déjà exclure un certain nombre de
véhicules des territoires vous avez
d'irréguliers il s'agit d'exclusion de
d'un certain nombre de véhicules de gens
qui n'ont pas les moyens de faire
autrement amplifiant une fracture
territoriale et sociale déjà très forte
dans notre dans notre pays donc
peut-être que vous ayez pas peut-être
effectivement les travaux mènent à une
nuance qui prouve déjà que notre alerte
n'a pas été inutile puisque c'est
tailler madame frigo c'était madame
frigo avant monsieur Meurin la député
que nous avons malheureusement perdu
suite à l'annulation de son siège qui
avait lancé ce combat puisque à Reims
elle était concernée en premier en
premier ressort et les nuances qui sont
qui sont soulevées ne changent pas cette
se transfert de responsabilité et le
problème c'est que si vous n'offrez pas
les solutions technologiques aux
personnes les plus modestes pour changer
durablement de véhicule sans que ça
atteinte à leur mode de vie ou à leur
pouvoir d'achat vous transférez la
responsabilité du gouvernement vers les
citoyens et nous nous sommes pour nous
nous sommes dans la logique inverse nous
pensons que c'est aux élites françaises
de proposer les solutions technologiques
et les infrastructures qui suivent parce
que vous pouvez avoir des véhicules
électriques il y a pas les bornes s'il y
a pas l'électricité pour les recharger
ça ne fonctionne pas et où les
carburants propres d'ailleurs et donc en
fait après avoir rien fait de 1973 quand
même monsieur mignonne à 2015 et depuis
2015 va-t-on tout le monde se réveille
en disant faut tout interdire du jour au
lendemain alors il y a une
irresponsabilité générale transfert de
responsabilités vous ne répondez pas ma
question vous faites le constat de ce
qui n'a pas été fait je l'ai fait aussi
j'avais pas besoin de vous c'est pour ça
que je me suis investi sur ce sujet là
mais vous n'avez pas de solution à
proposer à part supprimer bah j'ai pas
entendu donc je vais vous informer
simplement qu'il y a un rapport qui va
être mis début juillet par les groupes
de travail qu'on travaillait avec le
ministère la transition écologique qui
sont des groupes de travail
transpartisans et qui sont des groupes
de travail avec les collectivités
territoriales concernées donc on attend
des résultats importants notamment sur
l'harmonisation des interdictions sur
les solutions effectivement qu'on peut
amener aux gens et pour travailler
dessus personnellement depuis plus d'un
an et demi je peux vous assurer que des
solutions sur le terrain il en arrive
pas question d'interdire à quiconque de
pouvoir rentrer d'une scène dans une ZFE
donc pas interdire aux gens d'aller
travailler c'est complètement aberrant
c'est là où je dis que vous attisez les
peurs sans avoir été regardé les
solutions on travaille à déployer toute
une série de solutions qui vont
permettre à chacun de trouver une
alternative pas de le faire en fonction
de son calendrier le calendrier
était dans la vous savez dans la
première loi qui était la loi l'homme
principe de réalité qui prévaut vous
l'avez vu à Paris c'est pas moi qui
l'invente à Paris on aurait dû on aurait
dû déjà arrêter les critères 3 il y a
pas de quoi les remplacer on recule le
truc j'entends beaucoup parler de 2025
2025 c'est la mise en place c'est pas la
ligne d'arrivée la ligne d'arrivée c'est
203200 2000 dans 32 qu'on sera jugé
effectivement sur la baisse de la
pollution de l'air d'ici là si vous
saviez le nombre de solutions qui
émanent du terrain et qu'on envoie
directement au gouvernement pour leur
mise en place pour justement arriver à
faire les choses et quelque chose donc
ça passe pas par l'interdiction
de l'usage de certains véhicules
si vous prenez la ZF juste
laissez-moi terminé nous avons une
obligation de moyens et pas de résultats
il faut que les Français et ça en tête
l'obligation c'est une obligation moyen
pas de résultats si vous faites de la
ZFE une politique de politique
politicienne c'est voué à l'échec si
vous embarquez pas les gens avec vous
c'est mort donc nous effectivement vous
avez raison c'est notre boulot de
trouver des solutions à mi-juillet au
maximum vous verrez tout un chapelle de
solutions arrivés et moi j'aurais aimé
qu'on est plutôt des solutions qu'on n'a
pas vu ou qu'on n'a pas imaginé que vous
nous aviez ça plutôt qu'une interdiction
pure et simple qui va en rien résoudre
le problème de pollution d'air qui est
une un problème de santé publique oui
monsieur VII vous nous accusez de ne pas
porter solution à un problème que déjà
vous avez créé vous-même donc nous à
partir du moment on supprime le problème
effectivement on va pas la pollution de
la solution ici parce que la pollution
vous avez pas de chance parce qu'il se
trouve quand j'étais à debout la France
en 2014 et j'ai proposé un plan de
sortie du pétrole qui était structuré
dans le temps mais j'étais structuré sur
20 ans il était pas structuré sur cinq
voilà donc ça c'est la c'est la
différence d'approche et à l'époque tout
le monde ricané parce qu'à l'époque le
non pas vous-même mais les forces
politiques aujourd'hui vous incarnez
considérez que l'électrification de des
mobilités c'est ridicule et ça
n'arriverait de la même manière qu'on
nous avait dit que le nucléaire était
mort et enterré alors bon ça c'était
hier d'accord mais c'est important parce
que le problème de la macronie c'est qui
récrive tout sur les choses ils font des
objectifs ils font culpabiliser les gens
et à bientôt ça marche aucune
culpabilité monsieur Tanguy c'est pas
vrai c'est pour ça que ça a pris Arras
d'ailleurs vous savez très bien c'est
que c'est très mal passé à Reims madame
frigo a gagné 13 points entre l'élection
Marine Le Pen et ça quasi réélection sur
ce sujet là c'est que les gens pas
fantasmer voilà et donc et donc en fait
vous mettez les gens devant des
problèmes et une fois que vous vous
rendez compte que vous êtes trompé au
lieu de dire on s'est trompé vous
accusez les oppositions qui ont dénoncé
le problème d'avoir voulu attiser les
problèmes de la dénonciation monsieur
vous n'avez vous n'amenez pas de
solution je suis désolé ça marche je
vais vous dire pourquoi ça marche sur
les 43 agglomérations qui doivent en
théorie faire une ZF il y a un déjà neuf
qui le feront pas parce qu'elles sont en
dessous donc vous supprimez le problème
mais non elles sont en dessous des
normes prescrites par l'OMS encore une
fois résultat c'est c'est les moyens non
c'est qu'en fait une obligation de
résultats et pas de moyens en fait la
France en général a et s'il faut il faut
s'en féliciter une pollution
atmosphérique
alors la question c'est effectivement ce
qui nous manque c'est de savoir comment
vous y arrivez si vous êtes d'accord
avec eux
on ne pense pas que ce soit aux Français
de trouver les solutions
pour la planification mais si on a
toujours été pour la planification
aucune solution mais si la planification
est-ce que Monsieur Macron a repris
aussi l'idée de planification sur la
Reine des Neiges
la seule solution que vous avez présenté
pour le moment la seule solution que
vous avez présenté pour le moment c'est
décaler vos propres normes et nous
décalez vos produits
on a le droit peut-être au Parlement de
pas être de complètement fait de la
dossier effectivement c'est pas écrit à
votre place par rapport que vous avez
fait et vous avez pas écrit ma place sur
le plan Marie Curie qui prévoyait de
décarboner l'industrie et si vous ne
pose une colle sur le sur mon propre
plan vous allez pas l'avoir donc moi je
ne vous méprise pas ne méprisez pas
monsieur tanguyez si je vous dis je vous
dis qu'on a des solutions notamment pour
les plus précaires avec un leasing à 80
euros par mois et ça marchera pas ça on
verra on prend le pari
vous êtes d'accord pour faire
l'expérience alors oui moi je suis
jamais pour la politique du très bien
alors pour la politique du pire mais je
pense que le leasing concernera très peu
de gens ne serait-ce que vous n'avez pas
monsieur il aime les capacités de
production de véhicules électriques ou
hybrides en France suffisant est-ce que
je vais parler d'électrique ou des
brides il y a pas que l'électric ou
l'hybride dans les solutions
il y a tout ça il y a tout qui permet
effectivement de faire baisser la
pollution de l'air bien on en reparlera
on va arriver à la planification parce
que vous n'avez pas les moyens de
production deuxième sujet Bruno Miliane
le budget alors le budget ça c'est un
domaine que vous connaissez
quand même des choses monsieur Tanguy
vous en parler assez souvent et vous
citez assez souvent le programme de
Marine Le Pen lors de la dernière
présidentielle si je regarde rapidement
je vais pas vous faire tout l'historique
parce que sinon on va pas s'entendre
mais sur les recettes moi j'ai trouvé
que c'est un peu le concours des lépines
de l'argent magique 16 milliards
d'économies uniquement sur les migration
uniquement sur l'immigration et tout y
passe immigration familiale asile aide
médicale d'État social versus aux
étrangers dont le nombre est d'ailleurs
très légèrement gonflé 10% d'économie
sur les agences et opérateurs de l'État
oui on est d'accord jusque là où on
coupe je sais pas 15 milliards d'euros
récupérer sur la fraude sociale et
fiscale
où on les trouve mais oui au moment où
vous mettez le programme vous nous
expliquez pas moi je peux dire des
choses comme ça mais si vous n'expliquez
pas comment vous faites et alors la
baisse la baisse unilatérale des 5
milliards de la contribution budget
européen
populiste et démagogique pour enfin
présenter un programme crédible en
matière de finance publique
tout ça pour arriver oui
je vais vous expliquer alors déjà j'ai
essayé de reprendre de faire leçon sur
la réforme des retraites alors que
maintenant on a appris que vous êtes
trompé de 4 milliards d'euros excusez du
peu sur les économics ça va faire parce
que vous avez compté deux fois certaines
économies là c'est la révélation de la
semaine dernière excusez-moi je suis un
peu du mal à l'entendre là bon c'est
quand même un peu surréaliste sur
l'Espagne vous avez tort la banque
centrale la Banque nationale espagnole a
reconnu que 90% de la baisse de TVA
avait été un document écrit de la Banque
centrale espagnol avait été répercuté
pour les consommateurs de la même façon
au Portugal sur les économies vous
parlez d'un chiffre de 15 milliards
d'euros sur la fronde pendant toute la
campagne présidentielle pas vous mais ce
qui défendait monsieur Macron pour un
présidentiel nous ont expliqué que ce
chiffre était fantasmagorique et venait
nulle part et qu'on pouvait à peine
faire 5 milliards d'euros monsieur Attal
c'est maintenant aligné sur nos chiffres
en reconnaissant oui on peut faire 15
milliards de lutte contre la fraude pour
en fait même faire plus puisque
entre-temps appris par en commission
vous y étiez que notamment sur la TVA il
y avait déjà 25 milliards de fraudes ne
serait-ce que sur la TVA sur les traités
européens monsieur Mylène heureuse
aujourd'hui le Danemark a un énorme
rabais là Hollande a un rabais de 3
milliards d'euros l'Allemagne arabé il
n'y a plus que la France qui a pas de
rabais sur son but de changer de
programme c'est ce que vous nous dites
tout va bien il reste 2 minutes mais il
reste deux minutes
est une tradition politique de
fédéraliste européen que je le respecte
nous on est souverainiste donc c'est
normal de pas être d'accord sur la
contribution financière à l'Europe ça ne
fait pas de moi monsieur miel un free
visiteur et je ne dis pas vous que ça
fait quelqu’un qui n'est pas patriote ce
sont juste deux vis
que c'était pas sérieux ce sont juste
deux visions et vous avez dit que je
voulais sortir de l'Europe que c'était
deux visions différentes du projet
européen nous pensons que la France n'a
pas pour son argent voilà on a le droit
de le penser et au débat sur les
finances européennes j'ai tenté de
prouver qu'il y avait des programmes qui
étaient pas très pertinents mais pour
les chiffres du budget vous m'accorderez
quand même qu'on peut annoncer tous les
chiffres qu'on veut même nous à la
limite on pourrait nous le reprocher si
vous ne
si on le souhaite tous ensemble sans et
d'ailleurs le débat est très courtois je
remercie Monsieur Mylène d'avoir choisi
cette voix je pense qu'on peut trouver
des solutions après les Français
trancheront entre deux visions qui sont
souvent très opposants c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait il y a un an avec un débat on
se souvient très rapidement ce que
j'aimerais c'est en dehors effectivement
des annonces qui sont faites et dans
lesquelles pour moi il y a pas de
solution qui sont amenés derrière vous
soyez vous preniez un petit peu plus de
corps parce que là pour l'instant c'est
bien de faire des annonces c'est lisses
personne peut s'accrocher